hello Bryan yes there's something I have
that you won't not yes all right listen
here I don't know who you are I don't
know what you want if you're looking for
ransom I can tell you I have no money
but I do have a very particular set of
skills skills I've acquired over very
long career skills that make me a
nightmare for people like you if you
return what is mine that'll be the end
of it but if you don't I will look for
you
I will find you
then I will hunt down your family and
kill them then your pets co-workers even
that waitress you've been eyeing at the
Red Lobster you know that fuzzy little
squirrel you've been feeding bird see -
I'll kill him and all his fuzzy
grandchildren then I'll kill the birds
every crow Larkin stalling at the whole
eastern seaboard maybe even a few
seagulls a couple of fish as well and
when it's all said and done I'll dig up
the rotting corpses use the Necronomicon
bring the back to life just so I can
kill them all over again only this time
I throw in a few often scents of kittens
dude I just wanted to give you your
pizza no is it here I'm at the front
door
you're a dick hey that's 1573
I told you I don't have any money
however would you be interested in a
very particular set of skills your loss
I think it works got to the point
you
so how do we do well they like the
brevity of it perfect but if I was
shorten story
what's a complaint about what guy orders
a pizza he gets it I know we called it
taken and delivered but I think we
delivered a little too quickly I knew we
should have had the pizza arrive late it
would have built tension
I just don't think ransoming a pizza is
much to hinge a plot on maybe if it was
a lasagna or a human Nick this isn't
Silence of the Lambs
actually Hannibal led to delivering
pieces isn't such a bad idea I'll save
it for Christmas anyway we got
Thanksgiving coming up now in honor of
the occasion I was thinking something
that was timeless classic and a little
nostalgic let's say wreck-it Ralph hey
let's say no what well not Thanksgiving
Donny so you have a life we're tired we
could use the day off oh and what are
you gonna do on Thanksgiving stuff and
you more stuff you guys don't have
anything planned do you don't you have a
wife
she's with relatives then why are you
here it was part of the prenup and what
about your family they were part of the
prenup - that's one big breed yeah it's
kind of a big family affair everybody
was invited to talk about it except me
so it doesn't matter you're the only
thing I got so please tell you what if
we can't find something else to do then
we'll do it
but that's not a guarantee and we will
find something to do hey mom
no it's me no the other one um that's
your cousin sister come on Skye don't
fail me now mom dad what are you doing
for Thanksgiving Oh Harris don't suppose
you have in case you're wondering we
don't have an extra ticket nice dog yes
yes
hey I just figured that we should
no no I shouldn't have to pay to talk to
my own mother
yeah all right that seems fine uh 99
cents for the first minute two dollars
each additional minute
Oh saw your video online as you can see
my acting career is keeping me busy come
on
it looks like America's Funniest Home
Videos but we still act now that seems
fair that yeah go ahead and get an oven
timer see she's searching her kitchen
and searching and surgeons could take a
minute look I'm gonna check my bank
account
what was it supposed to be a comedy yes
Oh
needs work I think I hear a lawn mower
can I ask you something yeah is this
what you thought you'd be doing with
your life well my family never thought
so you don't talk about that much
my dad was into sports medical equipment
they called him the jockstrap King did
you work for him for a while you see the
thing is I was an investigative
journalist really oh yeah fresh out of
college I won my first Pulitzer expose
one of the biggest Ponzi schemes in the
Pacific Northwest even sent the
ringleader to jail your father must be
so proud father was the ringleader oh
yeah apparently the world of jock straps
is a seedy den of sin and corruption
well do you still talk to them holidays
mostly which is really awkward dinner
usually ends up with my cousin's
throwing congealed cranberry sauce at my
face and balls you yeah especially since
they don't get those free jock straps
more about your family Oh mine they
don't agree with my career choices which
one all of them
Oh some people take a while to figure
out what job is right for them that's
what I said but a parent need 42 is
their limit well at least you're not
hurting anybody
and that's why I like it here now this
place is kind of removed from the rest
of reality hey uh does this affect your
brows hand I don't know okay looks like
wreckit-ralph you get bitten by vampire
witches
tacoman been vampire witches really
removed for reality well I hope things
work out with your family me too
all right daddy you got us here's what
I've got so far
wonderful Donny I don't think I can do
this what what uh I can't play a
character from a game called sugar rush
I'm exhausted
the Tenno time you have all night
watching the place something about bad
blood and the tattaglias all right look
we're a professional film crew thingy
production I'm sure we can find
something to fight fatigue and assist
for a cranky foul line there isn't
caffeine in it right I can't do caffeine
why not it would be bad
nonsense this is perfectly safe what is
it
Bruno does home Brown it's chewy oh yeah
you may need this so what's in it
imported Turkish coffee three Red Bulls
and pant of sugar and my secret weapon
luftwaffe lozenges what missing feta
means what Vista gives them to our
Macbeth's to keep them in the air for
three days one of these and should be
reading like the Valkyries how many did
you put in there enough
Jesus man stricken see fit five seconds
I'm fine
did I fear mm Jets what are you guys
standing around for let's shoot this
Hawker now you only had a script Limor
eyes done bull crap well my 3:00 now we
can do it if we really try that's the
rest of course it is why I talking over
here when I'm already over there that's
amazing that's German engineering well
now that I left the world of copyrighted
characters perhaps I can relax for a
while without paying through the nose so
what's the name of this here place sugar
rush my god looks like if Candyland
farted out Mario Kart oh hey little girl
what's your name I'm just a glitch goods
bitch
yes you are no I'm not you're just a
mistake a hack a bug in our perfect
little world you don't belong here
that's not fair you need work I need
work you need where God is what you see
- stop it BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR BRR guess
we do you wanna do with your life shut
up mom well I'm Ralph
oh boy Rebecca I gotta say you really
got this glitch character down you're so
hyper and energized yeah yeah go come
out well you know I didn't know where
any of that stuff was in the script but
at the same time it's good to give every
character a backstory I'll tell you what
I'm gonna check out the price where the
hero's doodie scene why don't you look
over the bit for the commander okay I
can hear the people sing lost in the
valley tonight okay as requested I'm
angry Burt hi yes one angry-looking Burt
it's a turkey yeah okay no words what
are you gonna do with the turkey
director Vance an angry bird for his
video game something about flying aliens
why is there a camera on its head so
friends we launch it via catapult if we
can get its point of view oh yeah you
believes a turkey can fly that doesn't
sound very PETA friendly have a net
crisis done is plenty a change before
hmm oh yeah sir Lonnie made you go boy
these high def video games you're a
different from my world what should we
do dynamite gal just baby all done um
what you are me I think you meant
Angry Birds yeah um I think we should
Danny
God okay Rebecca I don't know what angle
you're going with but the commander is a
badass leader who sticks to the script
so while we try that okay your words
become colors when they leave your lips
okay so I hear you were married oh you
like that with you but on this perfect
beings I'm dr. tough wife you want a
meatloaf my right yes no God
so aliens attacked your wedding sure
wasn't one of the mini school plays you
miss hot so you were never married
of course not because you never liked
anyone I brought home are you talking to
it gosh maybe if you didn't leave me in
the same room with Uncle Frank for 20
minutes I'd be more novel
wait what God what you think we should
do I think your only hope is to have a
sit-down with Uncle Frank but what we
get to do with the scene travel back in
time at a time machine made out of my
nose hairs with a backwards yodeling
ukulele player oh I think it fits in
buzzers else's hatred for Thanksgiving
listing to thinking getting together
into being miserable to each other up of
German values and of course there's also
the animals to be bred when shortage
dust where you come in man friend
ceased escape you have to keep some lid
on this I create here we use this image
style parking device where do we get
that we stole it from Planet Hollywood
you remember Cinco DeMayo oh yeah get
with some epic drinking I'm just way too
close
alright let's go I'm gonna wreck it I'm
gonna wreck it I'm gonna wreck it racket
I'm gonna
James Enoch links it garrix
tres chic opt-in to the power how did
she get so high
come in Quinn I found her Quinn she's
staring at me she bothers gee I think
she can hear you
yeah what happened he shut on me can you
move
I feel like a statue of Lenin nobody
plus our our sent my friend I'm the old
gutter 9 Quinn it's too dangerous
I got engaged aliens attacked my wedding
I ended them off and last but not least
I have a nun problem and it's gone
forever gosh
all right it's just a little bit more
right there okay so let me get this
straight
my stump bird is roaming free throughout
the studio yeah well where's Quinn SSS I
afeard he has contracted vampiric bird
flu wait what the hell kind of turkey
sucks blood and gives you the flu only
the cheapest of birds imported from the
most disease-infested dirt farm standard
by the shadiest gypsies and Oliver
ammonia and where'd you get this one
from that is privileged information
suffice it to say it was a pretty good
deal ah well wait how come you're not
infected I'm German it will takes a
virus about to defeat my iron blood but
when it does well then never seen
downfall the last days of Hitler yeah
that well what do we do where is it now
oh yeah and I thought they were in
trouble Donnie we've got to stop it no
Karl has to stop it I'll help him no I
need you to finish the speak for
wreckit-ralph you have to find a way to
tie everything back to the Thanksgiving
spirit Thanksgiving sucks there's
nothing but a bunch of like-minded
individuals getting together and judging
everyone because it makes themselves
feel big we have the internet for that
besides that's what the holiday is about
helping our fellow sure man
fine Rebecca you and I are finishing the
movie together
but Donnie isn't he also fix-it Felix
how are we gonna get around that so
fix-it Felix jr. I'll see you left to
spot me you change your skin color from
white to black back to white again and
then grow a goatee very similar to mine
just to make me more angry that you look
like me all the stuff you just said is
true well I have purpose now there's a
little girl who wants to win a race and
I'm gonna help her isn't that right
Sammy
I wish you could deal with me I am too
sick but what if I fail don't worry
you're in the military now should you
die someone would come on
I'm go my friend how browse won't fear
nobody ok I'm not too sure what Turkey
steps sound like but I'm pretty sure I
heard him back there
I know you're out there you Buzzard
bastard
show yourself what the hell she got the
power son of a bitch to cut the power
how can they do that they're animals
whoa this is the sticky
what Princess Peach just gave birth
peaches are fuzzy go where's Scott ah
swing low Sweet Chariot that's it I'll
go in
do not worry should you die someone else
will replace you really none you our
last home where Danny as I said you want
on last hope right I'm ready let's do
this let's do this
so good now you will need this device
well now that I have this big empty
building to myself I can take the time
to contemplate in silence complete and
total psycho the serenity I have
Captain's Log second our Ze'ev entered
the third stage the gobbles what's going
on here where's Rebecca running around
in circles note that the koma koma koma
honey sprayer oh no it's okay don't
worry about don't worry about no it's
done at the speech
it may need a little work
no it's
it's perfect
and filming no no I can't leave you oh
it's fine
wanted to do
was to make somebody cry
story
shall avenge you boom
Oh oh great how are you going to finish
it MIT just yourself
so the mastermind behind the whole
videogame takeover was that's a lie
it's me Mario why because he feels the
need to be in every single game no
matter how pointless that's a night and
these time you have no more Dino's hairs
to make in the time machine
Oh backwards yo knowing science you
failed us what are we gonna do
Felix I don't know what are we gonna do
glitch commander Li he'll tell you what
we're gonna do we we just die where's
Tyler
my friends as we celebrate another year
let's not forget those who we have cast
aside sure a lot of us have made
mistakes in the past but in the end what
we're fighting for isn't a medal isn't a
race isn't a gold coin it's fighting for
our friends think we see nothing let's
say figured out how to open the doors
just had to say it didn't you
and you know those friends they're the
people you can always be with even at
times when nobody else seems to be and
when those friends look at some of those
lonely souls and decide that even though
nobody else wants them that they'll
still come together just for the sake of
being together that's when you know you
have more than just friends you have a
family alright listen we did this
asshole I don't even eat turkeys I'm a
vegetarian
wait to set up your comrades it may not
always be the best family but it's okay
because it's your family because in the
end they realize that I am bad and
that's good I'm not to us
and that's not bad
oh c'mon Berryman you have travelled
thoughts collective debt but I will go
down with my shipmates a lifetime of
killing all creatures great and small
finally a turn for because when you get
down to it what is family hey turkey
gobble this family is love family is
kindness yeah
family is friendship family is the need
to help all living creatures I'm proud
to be in this family
Happy Thanksgiving mother clucker
this most the hell happened here
I killed the turkey that's great where
is it
I think I you ate the turkey I don't
know it's all a little blurry I think
I'm on a sugar crash a food coma
it's like six pounds of tryptophan
I may have also eaten some eggs 700
pounds to be exact
she finished the script yeah yeah I
finished I would celebrate Thanksgiving
huh yeah
so now what
oh dear lord please bless this bountiful
TV dinner and the many preservatives
that went into making it may nourish us
and apparently help us survive a nuclear
blast moon amen
should be fun
just give us six weeks Oh Santa service
you
greetings Internet I am the leader of
swag the Swede Actors Guild we
specialized in remaking movies inspired
by the cinematic not blockbuster be kind
rewind I come here not to reward but to
punish an organisation has threatened
our very existence demo real these hacks
led by one dami ducrai represents a
grave threat to the guild besides being
really sucky even by our standards they
have continued to thumb their noses at
us hacks like these give us a bad name
they cheap it a very cheap foundation on
which our art is based that is why you
must heed my warning avoid demo reel at
all costs and destroy tallied you prey
that is all oh and also please join us
this Thursday for our annual swags give
me pot look remember there will be your
raffle so bring your cash and your sense
of fun that is all again